l'afrique du sud toujours en proie aux
émeutes et aux pillages depuis plus
d'une semaine le pays est secoué par des
violences suite à l'incarcération de
l'ancien président jacob zuma
les frustrations liées aux mesures
restrictives antico vider la misère vont
aggraver la situation sur place
la journaliste paul à c'est hier de
herdt internationale a suivi la police
sud africaine dans sa traque aux
pilleurs regarde je suis dans le top
chip d'alexandra en afrique du sud où la
police et les leaders communautaires
procède à une opération nocturne pour
essayer de récupérer certains des biens
volés par des pillards durant les
derniers jours
nous nous dirigeons donc vers une maison
où ils viennent de conduire une telle
opération
bonsoir qu'avez-vous en main c'est de la
farine des produits qui ont été volés
oui comment savez vous qu'ils ont été
volés
on a eu un tuyau et qui vit ici c'est
quelqu'un qui est à l'intérieur
ok allons à l'intérieur et voyons qui
participe au pillage
donc nous marchons entre les maisons
d'habitants du township d'alexandra ce
sont souvent des gens du quartier qui
s'adresse à la police ou à des leaders
locaux pour leur dire que leurs voisins
ont des produits qu'ils n'avaient pas la
veille et c'est comme ça que la police
ait des tuyaux sur les gens qui ont
commis des pillages des derniers jours
voilà nous entrons dans la maison de
quelqu'un qui a volé des produits doux
swing swing staff
alors qu'est ce que c'est lisse et sept
tours ça c'est une porte volée et il ya
du carrelage et d'autres trucs comme
vous pouvez voir là-bas dans la voiture
le type là c'est lui qui a pris tous ces
trucs
voilà le suspect comment savez vous
quelles sont les choses qui ont été
volés et celles qui appartiennent f
dans le cas présent c'est le jeune homme
tout ce qui lie à issy a été volé par
ses amis qu'ils ont apportées ici
certaines choses ont déjà été emportées
ailleurs pour être vendus je ne sais pas
où
ou l'emmener vous en cellule que va-t-il
lui arriver maintenant ce que nous
disons en tant que membre de cette
communauté c'est que les jambes alex
endroit doivent venir à nous et résister
il faut s'assurer que maison par maison
nous reprenons tout ce qui a été volé et
que nous nous rendions que les gens
viennent réclamer leurs biens ici il
n'ya pas de tour peine mort ni de beau
magasin mais ici l'endroit des bordés
d'argent liquide
les gens marchent une minute pour aller
prendre quelque chose et reviennent pour
arranger leur maison avec ou en faire
autre chose il ya des chances que ce
soit lente ses voisins qui a dénoncé le
jeune homme mais il s'est couvert le
visage et ne veut pas nous parler
j'essaie de trouver un autre voisin qui
acceptera de nous parler voici encore
d'autres produits volés que la police en
porte pour les confisquer et policiers
sont donc en train de charger dans leur
véhicule ce qui a été saisi dans cette
maison est parmi les biens volés il ya
un certain nombre de portes un blog wc
et un pot de peinture m
[Musique]
ja
nous sommes maintenant au qg de la
police où sont déchargées certains des
produits volés qu'ils ont réussi à
récupérer dans combien de logements avez
vous pu aller cette nuit et combien de
choses avez vous récupéré
nous avons récupéré beaucoup de choses
et nous sommes allés dans sept logements
ensuite je pense que demain nous
repartirons sur une autre intervention
qui vous donne les informations sur qui
a pillé ces choses et où elle se trouve
les gens de la communauté d'alex ce sont
eux qui nous donne les informations les
honnêtes gens de la communauté d'alex
parce que maintenant ils en ont
ras-le-bol de ce qui est en train de se
passer et ils voient que c'est quelque
chose de mal je suis ici devant le
commissariat principal d'alexandra le
suspect a été amenée ici et il est
détenu dans une des cellules
il y a peu de temps il n'y avait pas
d'électricité dans ce quartier et les
policiers devaient s'éclairer avec la
torche d'un téléphone portable pour
travailler cela vous donne une idée des
circonstances et des défis auxquels la
police doit faire face en afrique du sud
alors qu'elle s'efforce de gérer la
recrudescence de violences actuelles
paul haslinger rt alexandra